des cas l'image vous allez voir que
quand j'étais petit j'avais 12 ans je
savais déjà ce que je voulais faire tous
mes petits camarades chercher
désespérément ce qu'ils allaient faire
de leur vie marquée à 10 12 ans j'ai
encore le temps moi tranquille je savais
je voulais être prof de sport alors là
c'est simple quand on connaît l'objectif
on met le plan d'action en face et on y
va une fois un bac c'est loin je vais
vers le bac je passe mon bac j'ai mon
bac
ensuite faut que je passe le concours de
lure est ce qu'on appelle les staps
aujourd'hui on court que j'obtiens du
sport à outrance et me voilà fort de mes
convictions et mes compétences en créer
dans un chemin que je croyais être assez
depuis mon plus jeune âge mais voilà la
vie est pleine de surprises et il aura
fallu que quelques mois pour anéantir ce
chemin si bien tracé déchirure
ligamentaire d'un côté claquage de
l'autre et c'est même sans pouvoir vous
souhaitez que je quitte peut-être base
cette orientation que je croyais
connaître pendant que mes petits
camarades de tout compte fait ils nous
ont trouvé leur voie et continuent leur
chemin
alors que faire changer de voie c'est
pas bien grave
j'aime la nature je vais donc travailler
dans les eaux et forêts cours par
correspondance version accélérée car il
convient de réapprendre tout un nouveau
monde
six mois de travail intense et je me
retrouve de nouveaux prêts à affronter
un nouveau challenge
mais voilà la vie est pleine de
surprises et quelques semaines avant de
passer le concours
je reçois un courrier qui stipule vous
n'êtes pas admis à passer le concours
raison invoquée trop diplômés cherchez
l'erreur alors que faire ça fait deux
fois c'est pas grave on va aller sur
d'autres voies d'autres horizons au
hasard pour découvrir
c'est ainsi que je vais commercialiser
des abonnements des assurances je vais
mettre éboueurs ya pas de sot métier
en parallèle histoire de pas perdre trop
mon temps je décide de reprendre des
études supérieures en géographie
pourquoi la géographie pour une raison
assez simple
j'ai toujours décrété que je détestais
la géographie alors j'ai voulu vérifier
en fait c'est passionnant en fait c'est
passionnant j'obtiens mes diplômes mais
je suis bien obligé de constater que
toutes ces orientations nouvelles sont
pas très passionnante
alors moi je voudrais que ma vie soit
passionnante
alors que faire et bien décidé de
prendre en main son propre devenir
je vais devenir chef d'entreprise waouh
ça c'est top chef d'entreprise c'est
super cool c'est très très bien mais
alors en quoi
cegeka un gros gros problème
je n'ai aucun métier dans les mains par
contre j'ai un atout essentiel
je n'ai aucun métier dans les mains
comme quoi tout est question de vision
et d'interprétation pour moi ne pas
avoir métier dans les mains ça veut dire
être ouverts à toutes les opportunités
alors jour je m'ouvre à toutes les
opportunités
mais voilà on ne devient pas chef
d'entreprise comme ça du jour au
lendemain effectivement moi qui suis
autodidacte
me voilà une nouvelle fois contraint de
tout apprendre de tout réapprendre
je réapprends donc et depuis 25 ans
maintenant je dirige une pme de 70
salariés que je continue encore
aujourd'hui de développer en parallèle
évidemment je n'oublie pas le sport
c'est quand même une partie de ma vie et
pendant plus de vingt ans je vais
pratiquer assidûment mon sport de
prédilection le handball alors pas leur
niveau
un niveau plus modeste tournoi
championnat-coupe modeste mais
suffisamment intense pour que le corps
encaisse bien et ce qui finit toujours
par arriver quand on pousse la machine
un peu loin arrive le corps fatigué mais
bon c'est pas très grave
la médecine est bien fait je me gave
d'anti-inflammatoires d'anti douleurs je
fais fi de cette problématique et la vie
continue
en fait moi j'ai décidé que ma vie
serait binaire c'est plus simple blanc
noir oui non 1,9
c'est facile et quand ces hommes
c'est-à-dire assez souvent c'est 200 %
c'est ainsi que je vais consacrer toute
mon énergie à la réussite de mon
entreprise
les gens disent de moi que je suis
super actif ok moi je cherche à savoir
si je suis super efficace je suis tête
dans le guidon 15 heures par jour je
résout tous les problèmes
les miens ceux des autres tous les jours
toute la semaine tout le temps en fait
finit même par croire que j'aime ça il
serait peut-être temps d'oser apprendre
à se connaître un petit peu mieux
connaître ses qualités ça c'est facile
on les met toujours en avant mais
connaître ses défauts ses faiblesses
il serait peut-être temps avant
l'autodestruction
vous savez avant ce fameux burn out qui
si nettement mis en avant aujourd'hui il
est peut-être temps ou alors il est
peut-être déjà trop tard la boucle
infernale est peut-être déjà engagés car
si je peux revenir en arrière
quinze ans de folle intensité 15 ans
avec la poignée dans l'angle le corps
abandonnés dit stop
le corps y lâche moi c'est physiquement
c'est a lâché d'abord fracture d'une
hernie discale
et puis c'est le mental qui lâche vous
êtes un soir au bureau c'est pas
pourquoi et d'un seul coup vous met à
pleurer tout seul et puis c'est
l'intellect qui lâche prenait de plus en
plus de mauvaise décision
et puis plus de décisions du tout moi
qui étais sportif avec l'opération me
voilà dans l'obligation d'arrêter toute
activité mon purgatoire pour pas dire
mon enfer va durer un an
je vais prendre 10 kg je vais devenir
excécrable avec tout le monde
ma famille mon entourage tout le monde
et moi qui suis un entrepreneur né je
n'ai plus envie d'entreprendre je n'ai
plus envie de construire
je n'ai plus envie de rien alors que
faire
ah oui que faire si je continue comme ça
je vais tout perdre
je perds ma famille mes amis mon
business
tout ce que j'écris et je vais le perdre
alors je décide de faire quelque chose
qui en règle générale est assez mal
perçu je décide d'être égoïste mais un
égoïsme particulier un égoïsme
constructif qui à cause c'est un concept
super simple mais qui moi m'a sauvé
plein de fois il s'agit en fait de prend
en compte que si on veut être bien avec
son entourage
avec ses amis sa famille ses
collaborateurs il convient avant toute
chose d'être top avec soi même si on
sait pas possible alors que faire et
bien reprendre les manettes du genre mon
chirurgien m'avait dit après l'opération
philippe site est hyper sérieux sur dans
sa rééducation
je t'assure tu pourra reprendre le sport
pour moi c'est important des vitrages us
la course à pied et ça tombe franchement
bien je déteste courir donc c'est
parfait
80 de rééducation hyper sérieuse et
effectivement je suis de nouveau top
opérationnel va du moins physiquement
parce que mentalement faut être honnête
c'est plus compliqué et c'est là qu'il
est important d'avoir ces amis vous
savez ce qu'on n'a pas perdu
moi j'en ai un ami hervé clé monde mon
pote et mon kiné qui est quelqu'un de
très pragmatique et un jour où je me
lamentais sur mon sort il me fait un
coup de fil toi tu es un challenger
c'est dans la nature alors trouve tout
un challenge pour te remettre en selle
et arrêtent de nous casser les pieds
avec ton petit coup de blues géré toit
par l'impossible tu adores ça tous les
trucs impossibles
qu'est ce qui est impossible pour toi en
ce moment et baltes chirurgien m'a dit
courir elle va cours a été gentil toi je
n'aime pas courir à leurs cours alors je
cours
et avec hervé nous décidons de monter un
team qui va s'appeler le no limit team
pour quoi faire
pour oser affronter nos contradictions
je déteste courir alors un petit peu
comme pour la géographie je vais
vérifier pourquoi je déteste ici
vraiment je déteste ça il me faut un
challenge pour moi et en selle pas de
problème le mythique marathon de new
york me paraît être un challenge idéal
42 km 195 en une folie moi qui ai jamais
fait plus de 10 km d'affilée et qui je
vous le rappelle déteste ça quand même
le marathon est dans un an
j'ai donc douze mois pour réapprendre à
couvrir correctement beaucoup beaucoup
d'efforts beaucoup de travaille
énormément d' écoute des autres mais
aussi de moi une remise en question sur
mes capacités mais compétences et deux
mois plus tard après quatre mois quatre
mois quatre heures du conte de fées de
pur bonheur
je passe la ligne d'arrivée sur central
park de ce mythique marathon
fourbu esquinté mais super heureux
d'avoir réussi un truc que je pensais
pas pour moi j'étais en fait très très
loin de me douter que ça allait être
pour moi le début d'une nouvelle vie une
nouvelle vie où avec hervé nous allons
construire notre propre histoire une
histoire qui va nous amener à parcourir
la planète pour courir partout l'extrême
sera au rendez vous et tout commence en
juin 2005 lorsque lou nous cliquons
sourds
oui à la question voulez vous confirmer
votre inscription
le challenge être les premiers français
à participer au marathon du pôle nord
le marathon le plus froid du globe une
course en raquettes sur une banquise qui
se fissure de tous les côtés
températures moins 40 degrés alors je
crois qu'au niveau de l'extrême on va
être servi mais voilà on ne s'improvise
pas coureur de l'impossible comme ça du
jour au lendemain il va falloir oser
affronter nos peurs osé affronter ce
froid le comprendre l'apprivoiser faire
en sorte que d'un ennemi ça devienne un
allié c'est ainsi qu'avec hervé pendant
9 mois 1
deux fois par semaine on va s'entraîner
dans un énorme congélateur vente ebay
vous allez rire encore plus tout à
l'heure ventilateur à fond pour faire
comprendre au corps comment il doit
réagir comment il doit agir
donc là je vous la donne est bien
volontiers on reconnaît pas bien mais
c'est moi et malgré les apparences c'est
gelé à l'extérieur mais dans la tête
tout est super clair très limpide là on
découvrir 7h55 km dans les congés haut
et on était super haut point ça paraît
pas mais on était super ou pas alors
tous ces entraînements spécifiques comme
courir en raquettes sur les plages de
deauville sont autant d'apprentissages
parfaitement nécessaire pour atteindre
des objectifs qui paraissent un peu fou
un peu fou c'est souvent comme ça qu'on
m'appelle c'est ainsi qu'en en avril
2006 en compagnie de 54 athlètes de 12
nationalités différentes
nous prenons le départ du marathon le
plus froid du globe pour quelques heures
plus tard terminé à la quatrième place
de ce marathon gelé exténué fourbu mais
alors avec une banane comme ça un
enthousiasme fou une exaltation dingue
d'avoir réussi un truc on pensait
parfaitement inaccessible pour nous
alors évidemment un projet extrêmement
va en amener d'autres d'autres types
d'apprentissage d'autres entraînements
spécifiques on va rencontrer nos pères
pour acculer la connaissance et quelques
mois plus tard on va se retrouver cette
fois en antarctique pour faire une
première mondiale
pôle nord au pôle sud la même année
parce que personne n'avait jamais fait
on s'est dit ça serait quand même
marrant si c'était nous les premiers
donc on a décidé d'y aller et puis avait
deux courses d'organiser un marathon et
le lendemain à 100 km en conditions
polaires ou ans inscrits aux deux et ont
fini troisièmes sur les deux courses
mais y'a pas besoin d'aller aux
antipodes
en france on a des paysages et des
courses magnifiques une seule celle ci
magnifique là on est à 3000 au pied d'un
glacier
c'est une course qui s'appelle la petite
trotte à léon j'adore ce nom petit trot
taleo l'impression que ça va être sympa
quoi
on part de chamonix ont fait le tour du
mont blanc vient chamonix france suisse
italie tout par les crêtes
c'est ce col à franchir trois plus de
3200 45 km vingt mille mètres de
dénivelé positif et négatif on va mettre
108 heures pour faire cette course sur
108 eur un an mis 4 on sait en france
c'est super et puis évidemment on a
voulu tâter du désert un désert quand
même donc on fait une course qui
s'appelle la transe 333 en egypte comme
son nom l'indiqué 333 km en non-stop
désert noir désert rose désert blanc une
course magnifique
pour être très honnête c'est le mental
qui nous a emmenés au bout de cette
course parce qu'on a envisagé abandonné
pas longtemps m'enfin l'envisager quand
même et le mental nous emmener au bout
en 105 heures et puis et puis comme
antoine vous l'a dit tout à l'heure
quand les genoux sont secoués quand les
tendons veulent plus et ben on attaque
les pages blanches et on appelle antoine
et on fait une petite traversée de la
méditerranée en pirogue page blanche
total on n'y connaissez rien comme vous
voulez vous l'a dit tout à l'heure
quatre-vingt mille coups de pagaie nous
qui n'avions jamais pagaie super gros
souvenirs et puis la mythique badwater
alors ces deux courses à elle est
géniale
elle est particulière à deux titres la
première c'est réputé la course la plus
dure au monde
il s'agit en effet de traverser la
vallée de la mort aux états unis la
death valley en plein mois de juillet
sinon c'est pas drôle donc donc il fait
50 degrés le sol est à 90 degrés le jour
comme la nuit
il nous faudra d'ailleurs trois paires
de chaussures pour aller au bout de
cette course
217 km 4000 positif mais plus que
l'enfer de cette course c'est l'enfer
dans les conditions dans lesquelles je
suis parti faire cette course c'était en
souvenez vous cette époque là c'était
pas glop un crise bancaire crise
financière crise éco plus nous a une
grosse crise interne au niveau de la
boîte j'ai beaucoup de déconvenues chez
elle plus trop où j'allais ce que je
faisais et quoi faire on m'invite à
faire cette course c'est sur invitation
c'est unique on va jamais me le refaire
j'y vais et je laisse entreprises en
l'état où elle est où j'y vais pas tant
pis et puis j'essaie de sauver
l'entreprise
eh bien là encore il faut user et abuser
de cet égoïsme constructif s'arrêtait
sur soi qu'est-ce qui se passe pourquoi
je suis dans cet état là pourquoi je
n'arrive plus à diriger et l'analyse
était super limpide j'étais tellement ou
tellement lessivé à cette époque là
incapable de prendre une décision ce qui
pointent un manager c'est catastrophique
depuis prendre de décision donc il faut
que j'aille me ressourcer faut que
j'aille me rebooster fogel m'oxygéner et
moi ça c'est par le sport
donc j'ai décidé d'accepter et d'y aller
je fais cette course géniale je reviens
à booster comme jamais de nouveau apte à
prendre des décisions qui a priori
étaient plutôt bonnes puisque
aujourd'hui mon groupe va plutôt bien
alors que la crise est toujours là
alors cette vie cette nouvelle vie
sportive m'a amené à voir l'un
l'entreprise autrement avoir créé et
développé mon entreprise pendant 25 ans
ça a été je vous assure une folle
exaltation je suis bien obligé de
constater qu'avec le temps qui passe la
passion s'essouffle et l' enthousiasme
certain ce que je ce que je voudrais
faire pour ce que je voudrais faire pour
demain c'est vivre l'entreprise
autrement et pour vivre l'entreprise
autrement je vais oser deux choses la
première je vais oser l'autre vous savez
l'autre celui qui est à côté de vous
tous les jours au quotidien avec ses
compétences avec sa complémentarité
je vais l'osé celui-là et puis je vais
oser briser la peur propriétaire vous
savez ici c'est ma boîte ya que moi qui
sache à faire tourner c'est faux c'est
ma boîte d'accord mais non il n'y a pas
que moi qui sache la faire tourner s'ils
cherchent bien et peut-être même dans
mes collaborateurs quelqu'un de plus à
même que moi de l'emmener là où je veux
qu elle s collaborateurs je les trouvais
aujourd'hui c'est lui qui dirige mon
groupe
alors souvenez vous je vous avais dit et
25 ans mon objectif c'était de vivre une
vie passionnante cette ville j'ai vécu
génial avec ses hauts ses bas ses échecs
ses réussites ses chemins de traverse
mais je les ai vécus
ce que je voudrais maintenant pour les
25 prochaines années
c'est de vivre une nouvelle vie riche de
rencontres riches d'expériences riches
de partage alors fort de mes acquis de
mes compétences de mes convictions de
mes croyances sportif professionnel
personnel mais surtout surtout fort de
ma capacité à tout remettre à plat
à chaque instant à chaque instant à ne
jamais croire que les choses sont gravés
dans le marbre que les choses sont actés
je décide d'orienter ma vie
professionnelle et de devenir consultant
conférencier pour pouvoir parler à
loisir de l'interconnexion entre le
sport et l'entreprise c'est d'ailleurs
pourquoi je suis devant vous aujourd'hui
alors pourquoi vous avoir parlé de tout
ce parcours pour vous montrer que rien
rien n'est jamais acquis que nos
connaissances sont sans cesse remise en
question que nos croyances peuvent
changer et que tout ça c'est absolument
génial c'est génial parce que c'est ça
qui fait la richesse de nos vies pour
vous montrer qu'il faut oser briser vos
peurs les apprivoiser les désarticulé et
vous en servir de levier pour construire
votre propre devenir
je vous en prie vraiment ne vous
interdisez jamais rien
autorisez vous agrandir et continuer cet
apprentissage éternelle de cette
magnifique aventure qu'est la vie que
votre vie je vous remercie